good morning everybody big happy happy
day today seven o'clock after spending
just shy of six years detained in iran
nazanin zagari ratcliff is back home
touching down in the early hours of this
morning the british government settled
an historic debt with the iranian
administration securing nazanin's
release as well as that of fellow dual
national anush ashuri we'll speak to the
foreign office minister james cleverley
as well as nazanin's friends and
anusha's mp during the course of the
programme this morning it's thursday the
17th of march saint patrick's day green
guinness everywhere she's home nazareth
zagari ratcliff arrives back in the uk
after a six-year ordeal in iran
a wave and a smile as she walked off the
plane at raf brise norton along with
fellow detainee anusha shuri just after
one o'clock this very morning
nazanin reunited with her loved ones on
british soil as her husband says it's
time they can be a normal family once
again
do it's not nice
that's lovely do i smell nice this was
the moment a young girl got her parents
back together again
in other news no safe haven fears for
the well-being of hundreds in the
besieged ukrainian city of mariopol
after russian forces bombed a theater
being used as a shelter
in the southern port city of odessa the
streets are deserted as fears of a
russian attack grow
chelsea goes through to the champions
league quarter-finals despite sanctions
hanging over their club and current
owner roman abramovich
and ed sheeran's copyright case
continues with music experts divided
over where the shape of you ripped off
another song
also ahead on the program for you this
morning
i'm going to be speaking to the
ukrainian mp who's taken up arms and is
fighting for his region in the south of
the country
and a free house for refugees we'll chat
to the pub owner who's converting his
hostelry into a home for ukrainians
needing a place to live
[Music]
morning everybody british iranian
nationals nazanin zagari ratliff and
anush ashuri are safely back home in the
uk they're playing touchdown at raf
bryce norton in oxfordshire at eight
minutes past one this morning it ended
several years of anguish and uncertainty
as they were reunited with their
families katie barnfield watched their
homecoming
this is the moment they were dreaming of
nazanin zagari ratcliffe and anusha
ashori both held for years in iran
walking off the plane and on to british
soil again
finally they are home and they are safe
at raf bryce norton where they landed an
emotional reunion with their families
with her husband richard and cradling
her daughter gabriella do i smell nice
i
together again and this time for good
i've met the families
they're safe and well
people are very very good spirits i
think it's been a really difficult 48
hours the expectation
that they would be
released but we weren't sure and right
until the last minute so it's been it's
been very emotional but also a really
happy moment for the families it was at
exactly eight minutes past one this
morning that the plane carrying nazanin
zagari ratcliffe and anusha ashori
touched down here at raf bryce norton
they spent an hour inside with their
families behind closed doors talking and
hugging before leaving to spend the
night in government accommodation it was
a journey that finally gave them their
freedom from an unimaginable ordeal
nazanin's nightmare began in 2016 when
she was detained by iranian security
services as she tried to leave the
airport in tehran after a holiday
their hidden cameras capturing her shock
accused of spying against the iranian
regime she was held for years on charges
she always denied and subjected to what
her husband richard said amounted to
torture
it was his years of relentless
campaigning that helped to secure her
release including a hunger strike
outside the foreign office
persistence that finally paid off as
joyous photos emerged of nazanin and
anusha grinning on the plane that was to
bring them home their relief palpable
now the nightmare is over they can
finally look forward to life with their
families together again
casey barnfield sky news
joined by delighted foreign office
minister james cleverly my goodness me
good day at the office yeah a good day a
good day and it's a culmination of a lot
of
work i mean people have been working on
this for four years uh previous foreign
secretaries previous
officials uh but yeah
yesterday was a really good day a really
good day you've been intimately involved
in the negotiations for a very long time
uh in in with the with your respective
job what have been the most challenging
aspects
well
you know for much of this we we
we found dealing with the iranian
government uh incredibly
difficult i think the change of
government has definitely
helped
um
the
practicalities
of the uh of the logistics of getting
people home the negotiations of getting
nazanin out on furlough i mean it was
complicated
at every stage of course because of the
huge number of sanctions quite rightly
applied to iran all these things become
very very tricky very very difficult but
ultimately we you know we never gave up
we continued working we continued
supporting the families and i have to
say
my admiration for for the families of
all those uh detained in iran is is
enormous
and because of that continued teamwork
we we managed to secure the release
of um of three-day detainees and
obviously naznen and anushay get to come
home as well why did we not pay our debt
20 years ago as we were instructed to do
by the international court of
arbitration well one of the big problems
of course is because of iran's behavior
because of they because of things they
have chosen to do there are a huge
number of international
sanctions against them and uk sanctions
so it's technically not easy now we were
able to come to an arrangement at the
details of which i'm not allowed to
discuss they're confidential whereby we
can ensure that the money is for
humanitarian purposes only and that
we've been able to do a deal which does
fit within the international sanctions
regime that's imposed against iran yeah
but i suppose the question remains why
did we not pay the debt before now given
that we can pay it now and the sanctions
are still in place why didn't we pay it
sooner well as i say i can't go into the
details of the agreement but obviously
there are always two
parties
or at least two parties to a negotiation
the previous iranian regime proved very
very difficult to deal with and some of
the proposals that we had put forward in
the past weren't accepted um the new
government coming in did give us an
opportunity to reset the foreign
secretary had the first face-to-face
meetings with her opposite number in
iran for the first time in over three
years i had a face-to-face meeting with
my opposition um again first time for
many many years and i think that was
part of a combination of things which
enabled us to to settle this
so is it right to say without going into
any detail that we had been trying to
pay the debt for some time but we'd come
up against roadblocks
we had been looking at ways to settle
the debt that we conceded that we owed
we we owed this debt we accepted that
debt obviously the sanctions position
made it incredibly difficult
you cannot just write a check it doesn't
work like that now the details of how we
have done it of course as i say have to
remain confidential but it's taken a
huge amount of work to come up with a
method of ensuring that money is for
humanitarian purposes and that it
conforms to the sanctions that's my next
question how do we make sure that they
don't use it for arms well
as i say the the precise details of of
how we do this i'm not allowed to uh
discuss okay let me ask you a different
way how confident are you that they will
not be allowed to use it so we have
taken every precaution to make sure that
this is used exclusively for
humanitarian
requirements iran does have a
significant and meaningful humanitarian
requirement
and and as i say we have taken
precautions to to ensure that and how do
we make sure that uh future brits have
not put themselves in a more challenging
position because some would say this is
can be seen as a as a ransom payment
well look we've always said these things
uh were negotiated in parallel but they
were themselves
separate we owed this money it was money
that
as you say that we owed um so so that
was one uh set of negotiations about how
we at how we did that but we have always
said the arrest incarceration of all
those british jew nationals was unfair
it was wrong it was completely
unjustified we've negotiated very hard
for many many years to get them home we
always tell people to pay close
attention to the uk travel advice i
think dual nationals are particularly
vulnerable in iran because iran does not
recognize dual nationality
but we will keep working to secure the
permanent release and return home of all
those unfairly detained yeah but the
release and the payment both came on the
same day so you know it's not
such a great leap to think that you know
it was a ransom payment well as i say we
have always made it clear that the money
was owed we recognized that we've been
looking at ways of doing that what
connections the iranian regime make is
up to them we have always been
completely clear that the incarceration
of british dual nationals was completely
wrong completely arbitrary completely
unfair and it has always been in iran's
gift
to release them the charges against them
were trumped up we've always said this
to be the case
um look but we're just really really
clear you see the images yeah no of
course but it's purely coincidental that
those two things happen same day as i've
as i've said
we have always made it clear that that
it is not linked but uh the iranians um
the iranians make the decisions that
they make
in response to the bilateral
relationship settling this debt and the
negotiations we've had with this new
iranian government have clearly been
more fruitful and i've won i'm just
incredibly pleased that we're able to
help families reunite okay was it
medical supplies how did we as i say
that there's there's there's
confidentiality okay um more we were
expecting morad to be on the plane as
well certainly that was the impression
we were given yesterday by the foreign
secretary what's happened there well no
we were we were
always trying to secure as i say the
full and permanent release of all the
british jewish nationals trying to get
them all home uh as the foreign
secretary said in the house of commons
yesterday uh morad is a tri-national
he's got american citizenship as well
that has made it in the eyes of the
iranians more complicated than they are
obviously uh seeking to uh speak to the
americans about him as well we have and
we will continue to do everything we can
to get him home as well to his family
you're confident he'll be coming home
well look it's always very true he's the
only one of the three that is the only
one that was actually born in british i
know he's born in hammersmith i've
spoken i've spoken with i've spoken with
his
uh his family on a number of occasions
um we are going to keep working to get
him home to get him properly and fully
released well let's hope that is uh
before too long uh let's talk about
saudi arabia um has there been any sort
of breakthrough with the prime minister
and the saudis
well uh the the prime minister is
looking to help alleviate the pressure
that russia's invasion of ukraine has
had on oil and gas prices and we'll have
to see what the production levels that
come out of the uh middle east uh the
you know the prime minister has
a very influential relationship with a
number of heads of state and heads of
government
in the middle east and i really hope
that
um that that production will step up to
alleviate some of the pressure that
we're seeing but ultimately the prime
minister's right the best way to protect
ourselves against this kind of pressure
in the future is to make sure we
diversify our energy production we move
to renewable energy so we become less
reliant on all oil and gas particularly
oil and gas coming out of russia
81 people killed on a single day over
the weekend in saudi arabia three more
um killed yesterday we were told that
the prime minister brought up human
rights abuses when he was speaking to
the saudis it used to be a region that
you were particularly involved with
middle east minister of course what
particular human rights abuses would you
have wanted the prime minister to bring
up with the saudis well the uk has a
long-standing and in-principle
opposition to the death penalty we bring
that up when we speak with any country
that has the uh death penalty that would
have been brought up by the prime
minister it would have been brought up
with the prime minister i brought up
when i was the minister responsible for
our relationship uh with the middle east
i brought it up with those countries in
the middle east that retain the death
penalty
um and we do bring up uh human rights
more generally we defend human rights
defenders in the middle east including
in saudi arabia and we we do have
regularly very frank conversations with
them about this
we do of course need to maintain a
strong working relationship with saudi
it is a very significant and influential
country in the region and in the islamic
world but we do not hold back when we
have conversations with the saudis and
others about these issues what do we say
to them about the way they treat women
well we we have been um
critical about uh the the role of women
in saudi society i'm pleased to say
actually that over the last few years
there has been a huge liberalisation in
the lives of women in saudi arabia i've
seen the change over the years that i've
been visiting we encourage them to keep
that going women you know are are now i
have to interrupt that ministry from
there because i did see a video the
other day of all and you know i couldn't
tweet it because it was just disgusting
a woman who had allegedly committed
adultery
um officials chopped her head off as she
was walking across the zebra crossing
with her child
i haven't seen that i can't comment on
that no but
trust me it illustrates how women some
women can be treated
as i say i'm very very uncomfortable i'm
very uncomfortable passing comment on a
video that i i haven't seen i don't know
the provenance of um the simple fact is
that the as i say the the the
liberalization of the role of women in
saudi has been pacey we look to um
amplify that we want that to
to continue i've spoken and i've had
dealings with
senior women officials in the saudi
system that wouldn't have been the case
a number of years ago um we are we are
as i say we are always going to bring up
human rights issues when we speak okay
final thought about talking about human
rights final thought uh with ukraine
before i let you go um
it looks as though hundreds of people
were sheltering in a theater and um
direct hit uh bombed it looks as though
they were targeted that sounds to me
like another war crime well look we have
we have seen
obvious targeting of civilian
infrastructure that's against
international humanitarian law it's
against the law of armed conflict uh
we've got to make sure that we capture
evidence of uh all these incidents so
that uh so that the the russian regime
that's conducting this completely
illegal completely unjustified war in
ukraine are held account by the
international courts once this is uh
once this is resolved and we will keep
applying pressure to choke off the
funding to the russian war machine to
try and bring this war to a conclusion
as quickly as possible and we must
conclude our interview there thank you
very much indeed for joining us as
always mr cleverley thank you let's have
a quick look at what's happening as far
as the front pages of the papers are
concerned this morning and one story as
you can imagine is dominating the
guardian leads with the story of nazin
and zagari ratcliffe's release the
telegraph quotes her husband's words to
their young daughter mummy really is
coming home
the male does something similar with
mummy's home at last
now
the time she uh can start learning to be
happy again it says
still to come on the program for you
this morning
the shadow culture secretary lucie power
will be joining us to chat about the new
online safety bill
speaking to a military expert about why
the russian invasion of ukraine has
stalled
and later this hour we'll hear what
nazanin zagari ratcliff's release means
to the comedian and friend of the rakhi
family that's chappie corsandi
[Music]
latest intelligence from the ministry of
defense says the russian invasion of
ukraine has largely stalled on all
fronts it comes after u.s president joe
biden said vladimir putin was a war
criminal let's take a look at some of
the key developments for you this
morning uk's mod says russian forces
have made minimal progress on land sea
and air in recent days
russian military have been accused of
bombing a theater
in the uh besieged city of mariopol
where hundreds of people were sheltering
the number of casualties has not yet
been confirmed
at least one person has been killed
three others injured after the remains
of a downed missile hit a residential
building in kiev ukraine's emergency
services say the 16-story building was
struck just after 5am local time
and a fourth russian general has been
killed according to ukrainian officials
the 47 year old major general oleg
mithyav was reportedly killed during the
storming of mario paul nick martin
reports from odessa
another sign of russian aggression
against civilians in ukraine a bombing
of a theater in the besieged city of
mariopol the number of casualties is not
yet known but local officials say
hundreds of people were sheltering there
these satellite images show the theater
a few days before the bombing the
russian word for children spelt out on
the ground
russia's defense ministry has denied
carrying out the attack
following another day of violence u.s
president joe biden has for the first
time called russian leader vladimir
putin a war criminal
comments which the kremlin has described
but peace talks between russia and
ukraine are ongoing
the mayor of melitopol who was kidnapped
by russian forces last week has been
released according to ukrainian
officials they say it was part of an
exchange that saw ukraine agree to hand
over nine captured russian soldiers
there is cautious optimism that progress
is being made
my priorities for the negotiations are
absolutely clear
the end of the war guarantees of
security sovereignty restoration of
territorial integrity
real guarantees for our country
real protection for our country
but shells continue to fall on ukrainian
cities and all people can do is hide
if the thought of cowering children
doesn't stop the russian bombardment
what will
a very good question and nick is with us
now in in odessa um
uh hi um nick good morning to you um
eerily quiet i'm hearing there as more
and more people stay off the streets
yeah generally kate was it is he really
quiet except this morning uh there were
a
couple of loud explosions loud enough to
shake the windows
of my hotel room it's not clear really
what that explosion was it could be
defensive fire it could be something
else but we haven't heard any reports of
any damage but it was certainly an alarm
call this morning apart from that odessa
is quite a quiet place just preparing
itself as best
it can you know overnight uh further uh
uh east from here is that story in
maripole which is causing a lot of
concern we know that the theater there
was being used as a shelter for around
100 people
it was then hit
we don't know the extent of the damage
we are still trying to figure out how
many people have been injured or worse
and you know what's more heartbreaking
about that is that the people there had
as i just mentioned briefly in that
report had written the word children in
big letters on the ground you know what
more of a desperate attempt can you have
to try and appeal
to your enemies humanity than that and
yet perhaps despite that this uh theater
was still struck and uh you know as soon
as we can verify what on earth is going
on there and who is injured and
hopefully
nobody then we can try and bring some
clarity to that desperate situation
for in the in the capital cave overnight
we know that a missile was brought down
and that landed on a 16-storey
apartment block you know the capital
just like it is here is full of
high-rise buildings there are these are
people's homes and more and more people
are vulnerable to these kinds
of attacks so this morning you know
worrying news from mario paul we'll try
and bring more information about that
that group of hundred people taking
shelter in a cinema that was bombed
overnight okay thanks sir nick keep safe
thank you
uh the chelsea manager thomas tuchel
said his evening was ruined last night
by reports the club may not be able to
sell tickets for any future home
champions league games this season due
to sanctions on the owner roman
abramovich he was speaking after his
team progressed to the quarter-final
stage of the competition after victory
in lille
their club under attack and under threat
the abramovich era delivered every piece
of silverware to stamford bridge but
there are fans on this trip who are
ready to move on
and stop singing his name
we all appreciate what he's done for the
club where he's lifted the club but now
it's time to let that go and move on you
know chelsea fans are not the victims
here the ukrainian people are but i
think that there is a sense of grievance
among some fans because it feels a bit
like well
why we turn a blind eye to so many other
things i don't personally have a problem
with the sanctions i think they're the
right thing to do in this moment i hope
it becomes a wider look at how the
government look at money coming into
england it's good possession this from
chelsea it's a good ball as well
with everything swirling around chelsea
victory here in liel in the champions
league was impressive thomas tuchel is
expertly guiding them through this
crisis
but
those quarter finals the home leg
will be have to be played behind closed
doors because of a uefa
ruling tonight you can't sell tickets
chelsea because of the eu
um
sanctions thanks for ruining my evening
this club is still a highly prized asset
and this week there are all kinds of big
money bidders circling for chelsea
football club but at the same time there
are clear warnings that the way that
football does business has to now change
newcastle's saudi takeover approved by
the premier league last autumn has
certainly attracted more criticism than
when roman abramovich took over at
chelsea 19 years ago we know that they
want to get big big money owners buying
premier league clubs but we're really
concerned as an organization that
you know these opportunities just create
the chance for
uh
regimes with terrible human rights
records to use the sort of glitz the
glamour and the reflected glory of the
premier league to sportswash their
reputations
tom parmenter sky news
and looking at some of today's other
headlines for you now four people have
died and nearly a hundred have been
injured after a powerful earthquake in
japan the magnitude 7.4 quake struck
shortly before midnight on wednesday in
the northeast of the country
thousands of households are still
without power
the government's plan for new laws on
internet safety are to be brought before
parliament today eventually the measures
require tech firms and social media
platforms to protect users from harmful
content and the sector will be regulated
by the media watchdog ofcom
the footballer paul pogba has spoken of
his worst nightmare after his house was
burgled while he was playing for
manchester united on tuesday the french
midfielder whose children were asleep in
their bedroom at the time of the
break-in was told the news just after
their defeat to atletico madrid at old
trafford
well music experts have been thinking
out loud at a high court trial to decide
whether this ed sheeran hit has
significant similarities to another song
he's been accused of copying it's this
one we're talking about
i can lip think the whole way through
that song and i could listen to it all
morning um although it was never the
same was it after wasn't it um marx and
spencer used it on their ad campaign i
think um sheeran's 2017 track shape of
you has been accused of ripping off the
song oh why by sami chokri but the
forensic musicologist anthony rigliano
has concluded in a report that its
objectively unlikely similarities
between the two are a result of copying
however another expert christian siddal
found the melodies of both songs were
too similar for this not to be
considered ed sheeran and his team deny
any claim the song has been copied i
think i read this morning that he makes
something like two million pounds a year
on the royalties from that just that one
song
you can see why they're fighting about
it now to a couple from new zealand who
thought they dug up the world's largest
potato
only to have their hopes crushed when
they were told it wasn't a potato after
all see what you think it might be a
spot you like
here it is discovered by colin craig
brown and his wife donna on their farm
weighing in at 7.8 kilos they nicknamed
it dog
it was kirk crime the king of potatoes
perhaps edward would have been better
sadly
sadly the couple were left russet-faced
when the guinness book of records ruled
it was in fact a tuber which is a type
of good
so while they won't earn a wedge from
their find they
they weren't uh hassle of uh putting it
back into the ground
it's going to be tricky to peel isn't it
time for a quick look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
shariat breaks in the north and west
today but it'll be much more settled
from tomorrow island northern ireland
and western scotland windy night with
widespread showers some prolonged
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
and looking at some of the pictures
making the morning papers for you here
we go let's start with the eye has this
picture of a leading wnba basketball
star britney griner who was detained in
russia just before the invasion of
ukraine you remember the paper reports
that some u.s officials believe the
two-time olympic champion arrested on
alleged drug charges is being used as a
bargaining chip in the conflict there
she is in action the telegraph has a
choice shot of a u.s submarine emerging
through a large sheet of ice in the
arctic during a three-week training
exercise very impressive the uss
illinois pictured here and the uss
pasadena are twin vessels being used to
increase experience in the region
and the murrah has an interesting
picture here of a muddied
jockey
taken at the cheltenham festival he
looks uh very happy doesn't he as you
can probably tell perhaps a little bit
relieved as well uh jockeys were greeted
by a large deluge of mud after heavy
rain fell on the second day
ahead in the next half hour i'm going to
be speaking to a friend of naznan zagari
rattlers family the comedienne shapi
course sandy
[Music]
hello again everybody welcome back to
the breakfast show here on sky news this
thursday morning happy news for you
coming up russia's advances in ukraine
first of all though they've largely
stalled on all fronts that according to
the ministry of defense with forces
making little progress in recent days
new reforms have been promised by the
government to stop russian oligarchs
using british courts to silence critics
and our top story this morning
zagari ratcliff and anusha ashuri are
back on uk soil after years of detention
in iran
well the foreign office minister james
cleverley has been an intrinsic part of
those negotiations for years i asked him
a little earlier why it took so long to
repay a debt the uk owed to iran for oh
goodness i mean more than 40 years
we had been looking at ways to settle
the debt that we conceded that we owed
we we owed this debt we accepted that
debt obviously the sanctions position
made it incredibly difficult
you cannot just write a check it doesn't
work like that now the details of how we
have done it of course as i say have to
remain confidential but it's taken a
huge amount of work to come up with a
method of ensuring that money is for
humanitarian purposes
well we sent emma to the foreign office
for us this morning hi emma a very good
morning to you um great news today
although there is one brit still to come
home
yes that is morad tabas now when liz
trust was appointed foreign secretary
back in september of last year she made
it clear that her priority was to get
all three released and now in the early
hours of this morning of course those
wonderful scenes of nazanin zagari
ratcliffe and anushay ashuri arriving
back but
morad he remains in iran he has been
released from prison on furlough but it
means that he will have to go in and out
of uh prison potentially and he's not
back on uk soil so that's still a
priority but getting to this stage is is
the result of intense negotiations that
have gone on behind the scenes and uh
this having gone back to the 1970s a
debt of close to 400 million pounds
which has finally been paid and as a
result we see nazanin and nushay back in
britain and all along uh nazanin's
husband richard ratcliffe said that he
felt that they were being treated as
pawns in a diplomatic crisis having
always denied the charges that they
faced in iran but the question now is
how to make sure that this never happens
again and liz trust has said that that
is a priority okay lovely thank you
tamara's here um it's not often we can
have happy news from the minister first
thing in the morning no absolutely and
just those heartwarming pictures of uh
nazaneen being reunited with richard and
her daughter at raf bryce norton at 1am
this morning you smell nice mummy i know
you can just imagine what kind of day
they're having at home as they all get
reacquainted absolutely lovely and of
course also joy for the family of
anushay ashuri and his wife and children
who've also campaigned very hard for his
release so fantastic news for them
one dual national has not got out yet
the foreign office make clear they want
to work very hard on that and i think
the question's going to come out today
about how it all came about really nerve
shredding 24 hours for everyone involved
i'm told that even up to the last
minutes yesterday the foreign officer
member wouldn't confirm it even when it
was reported on the ground that they
were literally on the plane because they
knew up until that plane took off there
was a really nice version
airspace there was a chance a whole deal
could fall apart so
really really nail-biting obviously for
the families and for all the diplomats
involved but the minister wouldn't tell
us what they're going to do how they're
going to make sure that the money that's
been paid or however it's been paid
won't be used for arms that's right so
it was announced yesterday that the way
they'd found to get around sanctions
iran's been sanctioned for a long time
it was sanctioned by the eu in 2008
which is why the government say this
payment wasn't made before even though
they acknowledged that the uk owed it
then the collapse of the nuclear deal
and now it's sort of potentially back on
the table but iran has been sanctioned
by the uk on its own for the last two
years so they found a way around it
where they say it has to be spent on
humanitarian purposes exactly what the
details of that are they won't tell us
but it is clearly cash and certainly
there have been some sort of former
diplomats saying it's going to be very
difficult to make sure this is only
spent on humanitarian purposes but they
won't give us the details the key thing
though they say is that this new
government in iran the new president
who's been in place for about a year now
has been crucial in this reset he really
wanted to find a diplomatic solution to
this and clearly with some will on both
sides one has been found but it may be
that we never really know exactly what
they've signed up to and what that money
is used for and the uk sanctioned iran
for human rights concerns and of course
it's nuclear activities uh tomorrow's
take nine o'clock see you then looking
forward to it thank you
now the uk's ministry of defense says
the russian invasion of ukraine has
largely stalled on all fronts with
forces having made minimal progression
land sea or air in recent days western
intelligence has found that russia
continues to suffer heavy losses with
ukrainian resistance remaining strong
well mark voyager is a former special
adviser for russian and eurasian affairs
to the commanding general of u.s army
europe he is with us now as you can see
hello to you thank you for joining us on
the programme this morning is it fair to
say that the russian invasion has
stalled
yeah uh good morning kay thank you for
inviting me and apologies for the team
lifetime at one of the civil defense
facilities here in the city of
louisville western ukraine and indeed um
what was uh becoming obvious uh really
from the from the very first days of the
russian invasion has now become a fact
namely that uh you know russia launched
an invasion uh based on a flawed
strategic concept and major tactical
deficiencies
and therefore uh it's it's war machine
is grinding uh you know to halt
you know and uh really uh they're losing
they've lost the initiative uh in a
strategic and tactical sense in ukraine
we say that and then they bomb a theater
where maybe a thousand people were
yeah this is a barbaric act a major
crime against humanity which of course
will you know
these these acts will you know being
collected they're being uh you know they
will be uh there will be um a
international uh criminal court of
course uh a decision on that hopefully
uh sooner than later but that also shows
you the desperation of the of the
russian leadership uh they're trying to
terrorize the population they're not
even able to attack uh you know the
ukrainian armed forces there they're
really killing soft targets there's it's
it's it's unjust unjustified unfair uh
barbaric and it has to be uh punished
and and and of course announced by the
entire civilized uh um humanity
yeah it looks as though um president
putin's feelings have been hurt uh by uh
president biden uh who uh called him a
war criminal um spokesperson for uh
president putin saying it was
unacceptable and unforgivable rhetoric
by the leader of a country from whom
bomb hundreds of thousands of people
have died um
what do you expect him to do
next well putin first of all has lost
really all legitimacy in the in the eyes
of the west he's no longer president
putin uh he's really the war criminal
and the dictator of the kremlin
um and therefore uh the only chance i
mean
for him to to to assert uh to assert uh
any and show any success uh due to the
russian people uh through of course the
massive propaganda is to keep uh putting
pressure on ukrainians of course
unfortunately that means more and more
uh civilians are gonna be targeted i
mean that's the only thing he can do
um you know there they could there would
be um you know strikes here and there
against military facilities like the one
and with but the russians are running
out of high uh high precision
guided munitions and high-tech
high-tech ordinance and therefore
they're going to be they're going to
keep uh dumping dumb bones really really
old-fashioned style second world war
style uh and and uh and of course um
rocket launchers and and and the various
artillery pieces uh really this is uh
they'll be terrorizing those
neighborhoods in those cities um until
they're forced to give up
what um how seriously i should say
should we take the offer of peace talks
from president putin
again putin did not invade ukraine in
order to sue for peace he invaded
ukraine in order to really destroy its
statehood to force it uh to surrender to
russia's terms to the private of its uh
sovereignty uh of its foreign policy
orientation of its territorial integrity
i mean this is clearly stated
during every single
round of the negotiations uh and
therefore i would not take putin
seriously any negotiations for russia
are just temporary respite in in a
continuous
hybrid warfare against ukraine and the
west by the way in nato and therefore he
should not be trusted at all only
pressure and and strength is what putin
and russian leadership understand
some chechens have
we believe um turn to helping their
former russian foes um in kiev but
the big prize for president putin would
be if china agrees to help with
weapons and the like
where do you think we are with that
i think china is uh is majorly
displeased with the the way the war is
going uh there's no doubt that putin
had promised to to presidency
uh before during a meeting before the
olympics that the war would be over in a
couple of days and you know this was the
only way he could have guessed gotten
the blessing of of china to to to
proceed in a way uh you know let's not
forget the belt and road initiative you
know this multi-billion or hundreds of
billion dollar
project wars of china i mean most of the
communication lines go through russia
now everything is installed i mean so
this is actually hurting china's
commercial uh strategic commercial plans
for the entire for eurasia and its
global expansion so china cannot be
happy with what's happening uh the u.s
has issued warnings of course uh to
chinese officials not to
help russia i couldn't uh rule out any
uh you know contesting help or any any
any ways of helping russia kind of
behind the scenes but an open uh
help will definitely hurt russia china's
interests strategically
okay uh do please keep safe thank you
for taking the time to join us this
morning thank you
thank you again
uh let's return to um happy new year
should we and the news that uh nazanin
zagari ratcliffe and anusha essuri are
both back home
safe
this morning they were reunited with
their families just after one o'clock
this morning at raf bryce norton well
british iranian citizen natasha phillips
is with us now hello to you natasha
thank you very much indeed for joining
us
on the programme um
tell us a little bit about about your
background and what you thought of about
what you saw this morning
um i'm i'm half iranian my mother is
persian and my father is english and of
course like i think the majority of
people in the country i'm thrilled for
anusha's family and nazanin's family in
particular for elica and gabriella to
have their parents home it's wonderful
news and i think it's news that we've
all been waiting a long time for
um indeed so that that's certainly uh
true and there have been so many false
dawns haven't there um are you
where are you when you and thinking
about whether you wanted to travel back
to iran or not at the moment given that
this deal has now been done and
potentially i suppose you could take
from it that it is now safe for brits to
travel at dual nationals to travel to
and fro
i think that may depend entirely on
whether the interest that's owed on that
debt has been
addressed in any deal that may have been
made in the last 48 hours or so there is
still a an outstanding debt of more than
120 million in terms of interest on that
lump sum if it hasn't been addressed in
any deal and so tensions may still be
higher the iranian government may still
be uh thinking about that as their next
uh focal point and individuals like
maura tabbas
who have been placed on furlough
may well be the next form of leverage
the iranian government will use to try
and incentivize the the british
government to settle any outstanding
interest owed on that sum
and as we've seen in the past um from
bitter experience with the regime uh
they don't place individuals on fellow
as a gesture of goodwill this is more of
a form of incentivization um in order to
get the british government to act so i
think if you're if you're thinking about
traveling to iran um it may be worth
considering all of those things and
deciding whether there is still a risk
and whether you do really need to travel
um i think for myself as a human rights
reporter
who's been focusing on human rights
violations in iran for the last six
years um and for my team members at
kehan life which is the newspaper i work
out focusing on iranian foreign affairs
um we'd probably have to think very
carefully about traveling to iran at
this point particularly as the outlet
has been very critical of the regimes
human rights violations and the the
ongoing significant levels of corruption
within the government and the regime so
i'd say it's a decision people should
make very carefully and i hope that the
the home office and the british
government will release guidance in the
next day or so outlining the risk so
that people can make informed decisions
about traveling to iran
and why do you think i i wonder
why you think that they were released
now
my thought is that that is more to do
with a nuclear deal and a sense of
pragmatism rather than um any altruistic
gesture on the british government's part
the iran nuclear deal has been stalling
now for several months there's been huge
frustration on both sides and i think
the settlement of the debt removes some
of the white noise that the iranian
government may have been creating around
the nuclear deal negotiations in vienna
to try and push the the british
government to make key concessions that
they may have wanted
it also removes
the moral high ground from the iranian
government who may have taken the view
that they they're not going to give any
concessions that any of the parties did
to the deal
want if they're not going to be guessing
what they're owed so i think in that
respect um it may have been a practical
move rather than an altruistic one
okay it's great to talk to you um happy
news whatever the reason at this stage
thank you very much indeed thank you
well johnny is now shapara at course
sandy a comedian and friend of the
radcliffe family hi it's good to see you
how are they have you spoken to them
oh i'm leaving them alone for a little
bit i think
we've been um
so
um
all my family and our friends and
supporters of them have been so wrapped
up in their their story that i've been
waiting
i said to richard a while back that i'm
waiting for the time where i leave you
alone
um because i think that's what they they
need at the moment just to oh i don't
know and i i can't wait to speak to them
but i think right now i'm going to give
them um
a couple of days to
just stare at each other absolutely
yeah reacquaint each other and richard
to make that promised cup of tea that we
were hearing so much about yesterday um
this is a great picture of the them
being reunited did you see the moving
pictures of them being reunited at the
airport this morning i mean it was uh it
was beyond i mean this is it's like a
dream i can't articulate what it feels
like right now um it's been a dream
particularly as it's iranian new year
um starting on sunday monday for 13 days
and that's around the time when she was
taken so as the new year approached
again i felt bleak
i felt bleak and i didn't even i just
thought i should call richard but i just
thought it's so sad if there's no news
and then when it happened
oh i phoned my brother in rome yesterday
poor man he still can't talk to me i
don't think he stopped crying because my
brother was the first person
to tell me about all this because
nazaneen was a facebook friend of his
and he was saying to me that i've met
this guy richard and his wife in iran's
been taken away and at the time this is
back in 2016.
i said pave it's iran they do this all
the time she'll be out in a couple of
weeks don't upset yourself and that
that was my thinking because
you know we iranians are
it's not new this out this kind of
outrageousness from the iranian
government
um i mean it's why i live in london and
why i'm in exile but um
and as time went on it was clear that
this wasn't one of those situations
where they were
just playing a little game with with
someone this went on and on and then i
met richard um so this is yeah this
would have been about six years ago now
and uh i just remember
him saying to me when i said to him you
can speak to your daughter on zoom on
not zoom back then what was it face
facebook
facetime face time
yeah and he said well and he's such a
calm man
and he said
well um she's forgetting her english and
that really that
that simple little fact really broke me
because you know to to know that your
child has forgotten the language that
they
that you loved them in and um
that
there were thousands of little
moments like that throughout the six
years that just chip away at your heart
and now they're back together again
um i just uh
i can't quite put into words what it is
it feels like life life can go on now
for
for everyone because until nazney was
home i think anyone who who knew them or
campaigned for them and it was very
empathetic it was just this
dark backdrop and just seeing him just
watching now her coming down those
stairs with their new shirt and oh i'm
so happy for them all
and just look passionate a lot aren't
you you iranians
come out um
talk to me if you would please about uh
we've been hearing a lot about the new
leader and how it was because of his
election that this potential deal has
been uh made possible uh what's your
view on him
i think that how this deal was made
possible and why now and
all of that will will be discussed in
weeks and actually probably years to
come i don't think we we can know
completely
why this happened now or it was
because of a changing regime or this and
that and it all seems so um
complicated and uh frankly a lot of it
is so insidious to look at that i think
that's um
right now i just want to sit with we are
very passionate there's iranians love
two things passions and tea
so
um
they are
and all of the analysis of it i think is
going to be very interesting and i am
being very positive about everyone right
now but just you wait kay
just sure i'll have some things to say
about certain people
oh and when everyone's up there
you come and tell us whenever you fancy
obviously it's a breakfast show so keep
it you know more or less down the middle
um
as you were saying it's the persian new
year uh this weekend um i suppose that
would be quite a good time for you to
get together with the family wouldn't it
it is yes it's a rainy new year i'm
working as ever on a rainy new year
there we are but it is a time for family
and it's a time where we go and visit
everyone so i'd like to wish
all of your viewers who are iranian no
ruse p rules
well what does that mean
it means happy new year and um peruse
means jubilation and victory
oh okay i'm going to practice that tell
me again do it slowly no rules
means new day new year
okay
is a beautiful word it's a mixture of
sort of success and uh
victory
yeah okay
fantastic and
your excitement about it all is
absolutely intoxicating i i honestly
it's it's such a wonderful day isn't it
for the family i'm like don't ring
richard re leave him alone
don't wake them up
exactly well when you do see them do
pass on our congratulations as well
we've you know we've uh felt it with uh
richards as he's gone along with his
oh those twice i think he was on hunger
strike wasn't he and um you know he's
he's battled on he is without question
he's set the bar so high for husbands um
everywhere so um
i had a conversation with my partner
last night so if it happened to me how
long would you campaign for and when
this was a weird little argument but
yeah i'm sure lots of families are
having those discussions as well thank
you so much for taking the time to join
us on the programme this morning it's
been great to talk to you thank you
likewise bye thank you bye-bye
yep a happy day after so much sorrow
over the last few weeks where you have
all the latest as nazanen zagari
ratcliffe and anush ashuri are back in
the uk after years of detention in iran
not forgetting of course murad tabaz a
dual national who is still in iran
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign